all right don't freak out but it had to
happen eventually but before we get
started talking about falcon and the
winter soldier episode 2 i want to thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by bespoke bespoke is a
monthly membership club delivering top
shelf goods from under the radar brands
like here we go i'm going to unbox
standing up not optimal that's how i'm
going to do it a book for surviving the
great outdoors a commando wire
a knife like a manly man's knife holy a
knife a canoe knife they sent me this
because of the beard
i'm just saying also much bigger
this bag will actually be really useful
blow fish for hangovers they know me and
a couple of kitchen knives because good
kitchen knives are hard to come by for
those moments where you need
a little bit of country a little bit of
rock and roll every month they're
getting new cool products and they're
tailored to you based on the quiz you
take but if you don't like the box you
get
you can swap it out for another one
you're not obligated it's free to join
you can skip anytime in case you're
still enjoying
last month's box so click the link below
go check them out use promo code john's
20 for 20
off your first monthly subscription
thank you once again to bespoke for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now on to
talking about the falcon and the winter
soldier episode 2 this episode 2
you know what that means that means
people who hate zack snyder's justice
league and hate
the fact that it even exists have been
tweeting about that fact
for over a week now that's crazy and
yeah it's also
episode 2 of falcon in the winter
soldiers this episode we really see
the chemistry between the falcon and the
winter soldier i was like
it's kind of like riggs and murtagh if
they weren't as close but i like the
fact that last week we got the more
dramatic
side of the characters this week we have
more of the banter side of the
characters
also we see more of the the
star-spangled man you know
captain not captain america the new
captain america which last week we were
all like who
are you so this week we see a bit of him
when we first
see his well i guess it's not a
backstory but it's him like okay i gotta
gotta go out there and um but yeah for
america captain america he's like
prepping himself
he didn't seem like a bad guy i guess
he's got what three medals of honor
supposedly i mean suppose i could fudge
those facts
make that [ __ ] up oh we first see him he
seems to be a guy
just he wants to do a good job he wants
to be a good captain america
however he can't help but compare
everything he does and says
to steve rogers he comes out he was like
oh hey you
you you i'm like
steve wouldn't do that he more you know
who he seems like he seems like
the kind of guy who would be the super
soldier candidate
that tommy lee jones character would
have nominated stanley two she'd be like
steve rogers timothy jones would be like
walker he's our man why does my tommy
lee jones sound like huckleberry hound
but if for nothing else i mean if
someone asked you hey
do you want to be the new captain
america most people
probably be like yeah i know i got huge
shoes to fill i'll try to do a good job
and that's the difference between how a
lot of people probably
saw captain america and how captain
america's friends see captain america
they don't see
cupped in america they see like steve
rogers and his shield and
what he stood for and we knew the person
and we
know how he is like we know his soul
everyone else was like oh it's an ip
and now we don't have captain america we
don't have the ip and the ip needs to be
filled ip being intellectual property
so it's just kind of marketing however
he does have that one line
that was probably it was the least steve
rogers line in the entire thing
other than his general smarmy air about
him not being like steve when he was
like
stay out of my way i was like
steve would not say that the guy has a
lot to learn but i i kind of have faith
that he's gonna give the shield back to
sam and be like you know what i'm just
i'm not worthy of this it's possible
i hope it happens i hope he's just a guy
who bit off more than he can chew rather
than an
actual piece of [ __ ] also there are a
lot of super soldiers out there a lot of
them there are a lot now
there were a lot more before that we
didn't even know about remember when
thunderbolt ross was talking to tim roth
and he was like back in wwe ww2
we tried a little thing was like oh yeah
super soldier program you get the
feeling like yep that happened once
then we tried to recreate it and oopsie
daisy now looks like no
a lot of people have done that since you
know
in other countries and in our own
country there's just one
war vet who you got screwed over by the
government but he was a super soldier he
fought bucky bucky goes and sees him
he's pretty much like
[ __ ] out of my house so a lot more super
soldiers have existed in the past
also a lot of super soldiers are around
now because this whole
terrorist organization you know the one
with the red hands
they're all super soldiers not just one
all of them yeah i thought it was just
the one i thought it was just
undertaker's brother kane nope it's all
of them which means the only one in this
entire series this entire show
at least that has screen time in the
show i mean doctor strange is still out
there
i'm sure he'd do well you know he'd
probably hold his own but in terms of
this show the only one that's actually
equipped to fight them
is bucky because he's also a super
soldier which means captain not america
might
get some super soldier serum caution if
they do
because you know good becomes great bad
becomes worse
what is he smarmy becomes smarmlander
and the episode ends with bucky and sam
going okay
we need to talk to him he knows all of
hydra's secrets
we need to talk to zemo then accuse on
the classical music goes into the cell
you see
zemo sitting there you see daniel bruhl
sitting there and then the episode ends
which i
it's funny how one line can do this i
think it would have been cooler if they
were like oh we need to talk to him he
knows all the hydra secrets
they don't drop the name then cue the
music cue the classical music
and it goes into a cell and you see
daniel bruhl and that's all you get
you're like oh well zemo's back
i mean we kind of knew that from the ads
from the trailers i just feel like
name dropping him before you show him is
like we need to talk to zemo
in case anyone forgot who that is
audience
i'm talking to you so i'm glad zemo's
coming back as we all knew zemo was
coming back i'm excited to see him
in his gear his actual mask but i do
wonder
what role he'll play because you see the
trailer it's easy to be like oh zemo's a
villain great but now that i know
they're all
super soldiers is zemo really going to
be the villain looks like
this terrorist organization is a villain
looks like they're the villains and
zemo doesn't like super soldiers you're
led to believe
he wants to create more super soldiers
in captain america civil war
but no he just he kills them while
they're sleeping he's like i don't want
more of them
the world doesn't we need no people like
you so he probably doesn't like the fact
that all these super soldiers are out
there
might be one of those enemy of my enemy
kind of things he might be a wild card
and anti-hero maybe one of those
scenarios where what the villain wants
and what the heroes want
lines up for this one adventure so a
solid second episode the whole
terrorist organization they're kind of
generic i don't care about them
i like sam i like bucky i like them and
i'm interested to see how zemo fits into
it i want to see what he brings to the
show so looking forward to next week
of the falcon in the winter soldier
episode 2 have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you